Speaker 1: Let's look at another outrageous event
where Carrie Lake claimed that Donald Trump and
Ron DeSantis have large penises. This is the place
where we are now in American right wing politics.
These people are. Lizza I have no issue
with people, work comedians, working blue.
I have no prudish tendencies when it comes
to any of this sort of stuff. It's just that
it's pathetic that this is what your movement is
reduced to. Trump now getting applause when he
swears he'll drop an ass bomb or an F-bomb during
some of his speeches. And the crowd the crowd,
which is otherwise almost comatose from
Trump's boring stories, will get riled up
when Trump swears. And similarly, this is
Carrie, like she's the Republican nominee
for the Arizona gubernatorial race. She won her
primary a week or two ago. She shows up. And first
of all, interestingly, not taking sides between
Trump and DeSantis, which is a growing element
of civil war within the Republican Party. And
she says she can just tell from their energy.
Trump's got a large penis and DeSantis has one,
too. I can't believe this is what's happening.
Speaker 4: He is gutsy. The guy has bigger.
Okay. He. Wait. Let me think about how I want
to word this. My staff always says
whatever you do, do not say balls.
Speaker 1: Remember, Kerry Lake is
a pro-family, Christian, God fearing
candidate. This is who the evangelicals like.
Speaker 4: So I'm not going to say it. That guy.
Has a backbone made of steel. Mm hmm.
I'll tell you what he's got. I don't
know if you heard of this, but he's
got BD. Anybody know what that means?
Ask your kids about it later. I
call it Big DeSantis Energy. Right.
He's got the same kind of
body that President Trump has.
Speaker 1: So Kerry Lake very impressed with the
large penis energy of both Trump and DeSantis. And
I guess that's the new Christian talking point.
It's not who can pretend to be the most religious,
it's who can take credit for the largest genitals.
These people are just deranged. It's they are a
parody of themselves. This was, by the way, at
all over the weekend at a Turning Point USA event
in Phenix, Arizona. And it was just riddled with
lies all the way down. Another one asked. I could
play. Anything I played would be filled with lies.
But one other aspect. Speaking of Ron DeSantis,
Ron DeSantis showed up and during his speech,
he, of course, condemned the search warrant
being executed at Donald Trump's Mar a Lago. But
he wrongly claimed that the FBI has gone after
parents at school board meetings. Now, that hasn't
happened. I'll tell you where he's getting this.
But listen to this lie from Ron DeSantis.
Speaker 4: I remember the FBI at Merrick
Garland's direction being six on
parents going to school board meetings.
Meanwhile, when you have a law that protects
Supreme Court justices, is the FBI out there
protecting our conservative justices? No. When you
have violations of law where people are targeting
pregnancy crisis centers, are they doing
their job and enforcing the law there? No,
they're enforcing the law based on who they like
and who they don't like. That is not a republic.
Well, maybe it's a banana republic when that.
Speaker 1: Okay. So what on earth is DeSantis
talking about? He says Merrick Garland sicked the
FBI on parents at school board meetings. And my
challenge to you is to name a single parent that
the FBI arrested and or charged with anything
for going to a school board meeting. That's not
what happened. What happened was that there was
a memo released which said some of these parents
who are showing up at school board meetings might
be making terroristic threats. When parents
show up at school board meetings and threaten
all sorts of different things because of a
vaccine policy or a mask policy or whatever
the DOJ said, consider whether some of those
threats to show up and some of them said, I want
to show up on Monday with guns at the school. The
DOJ correctly said evaluate whether that counts
as a terroristic threat. And it makes absolutely
perfect sense. What Ron DeSantis says happened
didn't happen. The FBI was not sicked on any
individual parents and none of them were actually
arrested or charged. So lies all the way down. Of
course, it is a Turning Point USA event. And the
truth is this is this is not going to stop. This
stuff is going to continue. And we just have to
have a bigger firehose of truth to overwhelm their
fire hose of lies. That's really the only thing I
can think of that would help us actually deal with
this. We're going to take a quick break. We'll
have these clips on our Facebook. You can find
us on Facebook at Facebook.com slash The David
Pakman Show. After the break, we will hear from
some Republicans their views, just random average
Republicans, their views on what's going on. And
we will also see an incredible exchange on Newsmax
between the former national security
adviser, John Bolton, and Newsmax host
Eric BOLLING on the subject of foreign policy.
Stay tuned. This is absolutely incredible video.